so let's watch the video so you guys are
on a fashion runway and you're gonna be
strutting your stuff by putting your joy
clown on your hips and swaying your hips
we're trying to get out of the way a
little bit so you're gonna make two
passes and you're gonna look at each
other in the eyes as you pass each other
on the runway all right yeah and then ah
yeah and then you're gonna on the third
time you're gonna come together in the
middle you're gonna pose yeah and we'll
help you out the timing we're the TV
volume a little low right now but yes so
the key here is that when you start out
the game you're going to put the joique
on on your hip just go ahead and just
rest it there now on your hip okay you
know you're gonna be swaying that's no
no buttons right no buttons once once we
start good points just colliding yeah
since our room isn't as long you may
just want to like go a little slower
with your strut you know so get the most
kind of a thing now with your hands on
your so what's your joint con is on your
hip go ahead and push the trigger button
keep it there
together center stage we're seeing the
results so as you go down the runway
this is how your hips wave is that's a
nice one you have some good ones to rob
[Music]
that's fine I can live with this you are
yeah see a judge on your walk and you're
posing there all right you know we get
three or higher